Join me
Explore the multiverse
and ask the question,
What if everybody knows how
Iron Man became Iron Man?
How cap became cap?
The fun twists
that go in different directions.
And what does that look like?
It's like we want
what if as a concept
and as a comic book, it's
something that would always come up
in conversation.
It was almost like it was Marvel's
Twilight Zone.
For our show, we're not borrowing anything
that was pretty done in the comics.
We're riffing on the Marvel movie
cinematic
version of those characters.
That's what's wonderful about this.
What is concept?
Anything can be explored.
What if Ultron would?
What if Thor was never banished?
What happens next?
Brian and Brad pitched the notion
of using Rockwell
as a basis for the style of the show.
I mean, that's.
That's my bread and
butter. I love that stuff.
It's pretty exciting when you see it
all come together.
That's some of the best
storytelling we've ever had.
What if gives us a whole new idea
of what the physical reality
of the universe is, and it's something
that's going to be explored in other ways
moving forward
in our films.
I really believe
that deepening fictional
mythologies is a way to appreciate them
more, is a way to to understand them more
look at them in a different way.
And they've got now two seasons of what
if ideas underway
that that some of the best
storytelling we've ever had
and you may see spin into other
into other mediums, but
he's really the most uniquely beautiful
animated series I've seen in a long time.
Obviously, you can spin out any number
of what if stories
and it's exciting to do so.
Bucky But you were searching for that central thread that could make it feel like
essential viewing for the MCU
and what emerged was the relationship
between Captain Carter and the Watcher,
which is something that that evolves in a
in a in a grand fashion
in the second season of the show.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Marvel released more footage
and previews for What If season two,
mostly new Iron Man stuff.
They also revealed
what each of the episodes are going to be,
and it looks like we're getting a full ten
episodes,
So we'll break it all down in
what's happening in each of the episodes.
some of them build on the events of season
one with like the same characters
coming back in.
Some are totally new stories and
characters in other brand new universes.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course, I'll do full episode videos
when it does.
Premiere is supposed to release
sometime after X-Men 97, Season
one at the beginning of next year,
and I'll be doing videos
for all that stuff too. So no worries.
hopefully we'll start to see
more X-Men stuff outside of X-Men 97,
but I think that's meant to be like
the first real big hardcore X-Men
Mutant Space series.
all the new Iron Man
scenes from this episode look pretty cool.
They might seem familiar
because this episode
was supposed to air during
What If season one,
but because they were making this during
peak virus era a couple of years ago,
it slowed all production of Hollywood
movies, TV shows that
pretty much all over the world to right
now, based on the schedule of episodes
they release, is supposed to be season
two, episode five,
the midpoint of the season,
and it's titled
What If Iron Man
Crashed into the Grand Master.
and it's meant to be that episode
that we saw the tag for during season one
where he and Gomorrah show up
like a mirror, also got stuck onto the car
and wound up teaming
up with Iron Man to escape.
because they get stuck on sakaar
the trash planet.
Basically in the contest of champions,
he builds the junker version
of the Hulkbuster
they wind up creating the infinity crusher
using that to crush
some infinity stones in their universe.
then the watcher comes
and brings Gamora back to the Multiverse
Avengers team in the rest of the episodes.
So originally we just saw like the tail
end of that episode.
We're getting the entire episode
during season two.
that's why this Iron Man is wearing
the older looking Iron Man armor
because this was taking place during the
events of Thor Ragnarok, basically, only.
This time it's Iron Man.
Instead of Thor, they get stuck on the car
and they wind up destroying
that universe version
of the Infinity Stones
before the events of Avengers
Infinity War.
sooner
that winds up happening in their universe
then the rest of the episodes
in order from start to finish.
They might change this,
but this is the order that was reported
episode one is supposed to be
What if Nebula had joined the Nova Corps?
I know everybody wants to see
NOVA in the MCU at some point.
It sounds like they're going to do him,
but because they slowed all the projects
down, it might be a couple of years.
this episode could be the nebula
that we saw during What If season
one with the Black Panther, T'Challa
Star-Lord episode that these are two way
more chill version of Nebula
who wasn't working for Thanos anymore
because Thanos in that universe
had become one of the Ravagers.
but here's
the thing because he joins the Nova Corps,
this might be like
a totally different universe
in the Nova cause opposed to the Kree,
the Skrulls, Thanos, pretty much everybody
in that part of space.
she might be a nebula whose alignment
just winds up being more lore for good
than, say, the other versions of Nebula
we've seen before.
So she wants that joining the Nova Corps,
which is a little more straitlaced
than say, like the Ravagers
the main version of MCU Nebula
kind of went on an arc similar to that.
by the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
three, I wouldn't call her lawful good.
She's more like neutral. Good.
but it sounds like something happens
to this nebula.
In earlier in her timeline,
she bails on Thanos way faster.
And it's kind of like the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie Reed Gomorrah bailing
on Thanos much earlier in the timeline.
maybe, maybe we'll get some Richard Writer
Nova Easter eggs in there somewhere.
Episode two is What if Peter
Quill attacked Earth's Mightiest Heroes?
The Avengers basically,
there weren't clear if this was the same
Peter Quill who went with Ego's
the Living Planet during
What If season one
It sounds like it is,
and he just comes back
to take over the earth
with his celestial powers.
The other
funny thing about this whole concept too,
like Guardians of the Galaxy versus
The Avengers, is James Gunn
actually talked about this.
These are in his head like,
this is just him thinking about it,
that the Guardians would wipe the floor
with The Avengers.
But I think he was just talking
about the original six Avengers,
not like the newer roster was Scarlet
Witch Invasion
because you have chaos
magic of an infinity stone.
There's no way the Guardians of the Galaxy
would be able to defeat them
Episode three is called
What If Kahhori Reshaped the World?
And this is like a non-canonical character
they created just for the show.
This is like a totally new concept
in this universe,
the tesseract balls to earth earlier
in the timeline
when America is still controlled
by Native Americans
before it's been colonized look.
You have all these different tribes
of Native Americans in it.
Why is it falling into the Mohawk
tribe's territory
and found by one of the girls
that lives there?
she gets infinity stone,
cosmic level powers.
I don't think she turns it
to like a version of Captain Marvel.
Like she doesn't look like Captain
Marvel here.
she just gains infinity stone
level powers.
it is meant to show how that would change
the development of the rest of the world.
If somebody like that in that era
gained powers on that scale,
kind of like a bigger version
of the concept of
Wakanda is a place in Black Panther
and his powers.
the whole idea with Kahhori is that
it was never colonized,
never touched by the outside world
in that completely changed the way
their culture, their technology developed.
so this episode is like the same thing.
But What If for Native Americans, Episode
four is meant to be.
What if Hela found The ten rings
is basically a thor hela crossover
with the Shang Chi characters.
There was some early footage of this.
They showed off last year with Odin
fighting everyone too,
so I don't think
it'll just be hell on earth.
They'll be like the other Thor
characters to.
I know.
Everybody's been asking
when hell is going to come back in the MCU
at some point
because she was really interesting
character
this might be one of the episodes
with a downer ending usually most
What If stories in the comics
had really WTF endings or downer endings
I've already explained Episode five.
That's the Iron Man episode.
Episode six is supposed to be?
What If Happy Hogan saved Christmas?
This is exactly what it sounds like.
It's basically like a Spider-Man episode,
mostly centered around
Happy Hogan in the Christmas holiday.
Maybe when they were making this,
they intended to release the season
during the Christmas holiday.
sometimes that'll happen
with like TV series
that'll do special holiday themed
episodes, but then they get delayed.
It's like
the special holiday is nowhere near where
it actually falls in the actual year.
I don't know which other characters
are going to cross over into this is You
sounds like a Spider-Man based episode,
The last Spider-Man
episode we saw in season
one was the Marvel Zombies episode.
They're still doing like that
whole other Marvel Zombies series,
but no idea when it's going to be released
because they delayed everything
by a couple of years.
Speaking of Spider-Man, though,
we also got a bunch more details
on Spider-Man freshman year.
This like a totally different TV series
they're working on.
I'll do new video for that.
When they released some more footage,
they delayed it till like November 2024.
So they're still releasing it
like didn't get canceled or anything.
It's just going to be a while
before we see it.
Episode seven is a complete mystery.
Like all the episode titles and breakdowns
were released except for episode seven,
so no idea what that's going to be Episode
eight is supposed to be?
What If Captain Carter
fought the Hydra stomper?
This is literally meant to be the versions
we saw during season
one in that Post-Credits
scene where she found the skinny boy,
Steve Rogers.
He'd been turned into like that universe's
version of the Winter Soldier
in the Hydra stomper armor.
the episode will basically play out
like Captain Carter's
version of the Winter Soldier storyline.
episode nine is What If the Avengers
assembled during 1602
If you haven't read that storyline, it's
based on the comic book 1602 storyline,
which is like all the Marvel characters
existing during the time of Queen
Elizabeth, the first.
so like all the Mutants X-Men characters,
Fantastic Four characters,
The Avengers, other Marvel characters
all exist during the 1600s.
so the alliances, the teams, the bases of
power are completely different.
Everyone's aligned with different groups.
Like the church is a major force.
For example, Daredevil
is a member of the Knights Templar,
they still persecute the mutants
like they wouldn't be an X-Men based story
if they didn't persecute mutants.
all the X-Men and the mutants.
People with biological powers
are thought of as the witch breed.
They're hunted down and persecuted.
the survivor
of the events of that storyline
wind up being the Roanoke colonists
leaving to go to North America
to completely start
fresh in the new country.
but because they're titling this episode.
What if The Avengers assembled in 1602
It just sounds like
it's going to be more Avengers
heavy storyline
than, say, like expanding mutants.
Renner The really
only heavy X-Men based series
they're doing right now is X-Men 97
and like Deadpool three, for example,
and then eventually Avengers Secret Wars.
they haven't said
one of the new live action
MCU X-Men movie is going to premiere.
That could happen before Secret Wars.
It might happen after Secret Wars.
are a couple mutants right now in the MCU
like Name or Miss Marvel, for example.
We'll see a couple of others pop up before
Deadpool three, maybe then episode ten.
The finale is supposed to be
What If Doctor
Strange Supreme intervene
and this is meant to be the same doctor
Strange Supreme
from the end of season one.
They didn't say what the catastrophe
is going to be in this season,
but there's some new problem
that threatens the entire multiverse
that requires him to assemble another
multiverse, Avengers team, to stop it
that lead directly into the events
of What If Season 3,
which they've confirmed
that'll release sometime in 2025.
No idea when during that year.
but I think that's meant
to be the last season
and then they're just set up
the characters
to appear in Avengers secret wars
like some of the characters
the same way that they did
Captain Carter in live action,
but I think that's meant
to be the last season
and then they're just set up
the characters
to appear in Avengers secret wars
like some of the characters
the same way they did.
Captain Carter in Doctor Strange Supreme
in Live Action, even though those versions
were like a little bit different
in that movie than the ones from What If,
Right now.
What if season two is supposed to release
right after X-Men 97, Season one?
Like I said, that
might wind up happening like February.
so we might wind up seeing
What If Season 2 by like April next year
maybe we'll see
I'll do weekly videos for all that stuff
when it does premiere, so no worries.
We'll get trailers for some of that stuff
pretty soon.
I've already done
a couple X-Men 97 trailer video
all link those in the description below.
Really excited
to see what that's going to be like.
It's basically going to be like X-Men,
the Animated series Season six,
just picking up after the events
of that original series ended.
there's a bunch of other big stuff
coming up.
My Loki Season 2 Episode 4 video.
We'll post Friday. Click here for that.
I'll empty the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for my full Loki Season 2
Episode 3 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!